So the headlines going around on the internet
say flies can feel fear.
Excellent.
(Laughs maniacally)
Hello to all you fly honies, Julian at YouTube
Space LA for DNews.
Like I said, if the internet is to be believed
then we are giving poor wittle fruit flies
spaz attacks just from waving our hands at
them.
The news comes from a study from the California
Institute of Technology but there’s more
grey area than some black and white headlines
would lead you to think.
One of the study’s authors, Dr. David J.
Anderson, says we can only know if a creature
is feeling emotions by asking them directly.
Of course if you ask a fly anything, all they’ll
say is (rubs hands together flyishly) so the
scientists had to set up some parameters that
separated emotions from a simple reflex.
The criteria they settled on was that any
emotion has certain characteristics.
These “emotion primitives” were scalability,
persistence, generalizability, and valence
(which in the context of psychology means
how attractive or aversive something is).
The scientists put the flies in a chamber
and occasionally passed a shadow overhead
to simulate a bird or Batman coming for them.
When the shadow came, the flies would run,
hop, or freeze in place.
When the shadows swooped by more frequently,
they would run and hop faster, which showed
scalability.
They repeated this with food in the flies’
chamber, and got the same result.
This fulfils two other criteria of being generalizable
to different contexts and having negative
valence that overcomes the attractiveness
of that sweet mushy brown banana.
The flies would also take longer to come back
to the food the more they were antagonized,
and that demonstrates persistence.
Rather than just hopping away and coming back
when the danger had passed, they lingered.
If responding to the shadows were just a reflex,
then the flies should come back to the food
in about time once the threat was gone, regardless
of how much they were threatened.
It suggests to the researchers that they were
calming down from an emotional state, much
like how it takes you time to come down after
almost getting in a car accident, even though
the danger has passed.
All of this fly torture may sound like scientists
just being bullies but there’s a good reason
for it.
As first author of the study William Gibson
points out, flies have the same fundamental
drives we do, the four F’s, which are “Feeding,
Fighting, Fleeing and Fmating.”
But the deeper question is, “Do they have
emotions that can drive these motivations
or is it a mechanical response?”
Satisfied that the flies may be acting out
of fear, the researchers have proposed studying
the simple neural network of the flies to
see what molecules affect emotional states.
Maybe what we find in the flies brains can
be compared to what happens in other animals
or us.
We know other animals have similar survival
circuitry to ours in their brains, but we
couldn’t know if they felt the same way
we do.
Maybe it can help us nail down exactly what
emotions are and give us an objective and
universal yardstick for what to date has been
a very subjective experience.
Maybe it can help us learn about and combat
irrational fears too, like fear of spiders!
Actually maybe not, arachnophobia would be
a totally rational fear for a fly.
Most of us avoid fear but some of us can’t
get enough of it.
Trace explains adrenaline junkies here.
Extreme!
So I think this all raises an interesting
philosophical question which is: At what point
does a survival instinct become an emotion?
Do you think there’s a difference?
Let me know in the comments or on facebook
or twitter @DNews, and I’ll see you next
time.